hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and I'm Cody Meltzer I'm Jake and Cody
also just saw two as well
penny wisely and I was there we just saw
it together got right to it yeah high
budget story based character-driven
horror films I have been watching for
ever and ever and it was just so good it
was just so good absolutely every time
they weren't creeping us out majorly
they were building up a series of
characters that we absolutely fell in
love with tell us Cody Cody is afraid of
horses some horror films I agree with
the story part this is a much better
film but Annabel creation was scarier Oh
right off the bat when when it when it
turns from like Pennywise the clown to
like teeth clown mm-hmm with Georgie I
was like I'm not scared of this there
are some times but I think there was
like a scary moment and I lacked I think
I was more scared of a lot of the human
interaction yeah then I was with actual
clown interaction the true demon clown
was toxic masculinity loud in this movie
that's not that's the thing in horror
films that you don't often get is good
character work hey it did a good job of
keeping some cool elements of the
miniseries but it also just felt way
better pace than the miniseries who knew
it was gonna be this movie wasn't gonna
go into this for our epic so it felt a
better pace it's like alright well then
they each get their turn to see the
thing but it's not gonna be 30 minutes
for each of them it just felt a lot
better in that regard
a lot of the adaptations the place they
fall apart is by trying to like chop out
so much story to try and cram it all
into like two ish hours by just tackling
the children's story they nailed it yeah
and all of these kids the kid from
stranger things plays the character of
Richie the wiseass and he was
exceptional such a different character
from stranger things just yeah uncle did
and was amazing and foul-mouthed and
hilarious and he was the he was the
jackass in every group of friends yeah I
am just obsessed with literally Beverly
Marsh was a badass queen and we must
protect her dogs they need to be
protected
she's a grandma my favorite was the
little a little sick sad one that's my
that was that was my Eddie that is your
spirit animal the kid who played Ben was
so exceptional like he was sincere and
he was the goofy clumsy kid but without
being a fool yeah like yeah play the
fool card ever he always had his own
sense of pride even when he was being
pushed up against a fence with a name
getting carved into his stomach yeah
boiler alert yeah good yeah observation
that's it I know it's library kids roll
hard three kids roll hard great kids
roll hard they do yeah okay I agree with
you about the initial Pennywise
interaction everybody who's seen the
trailer knows what we're talking about
in the sewer drain more than miniseries
yeah yeah it's the first time you see
penny wise so that interaction felt very
true to the book he was like yeah he was
joking with Georgie Georgie seemed a
little too like into it for me it wasn't
super scary yeah and and that whole like
it was awesome to see a little tiny
child have his arm red knob yeah okay
not scary but the arm gets ripped off
right on boy yeah some of the moments
with it were it's just weird and kind of
Tarrant like I like that kind of stuff
but this movie had a hard time tone-wise
with with scary versus like kind of
cheesy or just like off I see what
you're saying yeah I I don't agree like
Dark Tower as well like I don't
I'm just like that was amazing I don't
know if it's every movie but watching a
horror movie sitting next to her
is a pure pleasure when something scary
would happen she'd be so into it
that right afterwards right after the
tension break when everyone's kind of
like settling back into her into their
seats she would be like yeah and then
she'd be like yeah I almost flicked her
off a couple of times there were some
scary moments I'm just saying that it
wasn't as scary as I thought it was
going to be this is the probably showing
too much of the monster that always
happens where it's like there were
several sequences where it was like okay
if you had stopped it there they would
have remained terrifying you went so you
went a little too far and then it
suddenly just became too this is also
the moment CGI where it suddenly becomes
too CGI right like I'm very aware now
that this is CGI I think a lot of it for
me was the was because it was a clown
like in the miniseries Tim Curry is like
he portrays it in a very comical way and
so this I think some of the funniest for
me came in like some awkward like scary
clown this is just like doing really
weird things yeah and so I kind of felt
it was bored that then like an awkward
thing for me yeah I'm not afraid of this
clown right well I'm glad you were
terrified to go even even in those weird
moments in those scary moments or even
when the moments words like super scary
the fact that we were so attached to the
kids really pulled us into the drama of
the moment and they also chose to like
focus like really focus on set like only
a few of the kids in the other trying to
focus on all of the group yeah and even
though those few kids who got
shortchanged have very interesting
stories in the book like by not focusing
on them they didn't spread us too thin
right
maybe I build it up too much in my head
that I was I was gonna be more afraid
than I was and then when I walked out of
it not as afraid as I was with Annabelle
creation I'm like okay well maybe maybe
the clown wasn't that scary for me in
the horror Department it was so well
spaced in the dream the story and in
between everything
it wasn't just an Annabel creation it
was like you were you were in this it
was a clear-cut horror film sure where
this is like shrouded in character work
and story and there were only a few
moments where like a few cliche ish
moments where they'd be like it wants to
tear us apart
you know yeah and oh that was always
gonna be in there
you always need that moment and they
just went for the easiest way which is
the normal way right right right right
it doesn't really piss me off when in
horror films people go into a
dilapidated building without a plan yeah
I know they're kids
look I didn't talk to kids when I was
growing up so I don't know what they're
like but it was so weird to be that it
never that none of their individual
stories ever came up until like way late
in the movie I'm like no I'm sorry if a
weird painting woman trying to attack me
I would have mentioned that right well
especially with unpopular kids though
which all of these kids were outside of
this one right root like you are gonna
be the first one to say it in the
miniseries is that how it was in the
book right yeah yeah yeah this is the
thing that everyone points out and they
didn't do it the miniseries obviously
they didn't do it in this and no one's
ever going to do it and every and
everyone always kind of is like oh I
love the book it except and the thing is
it's not the hobo it's not the hobo it's
not the whole whole blowjob it's me you
made yeah I mean I don't think it's a
blowjob after everything that happens
with the kids in the movie that really
has sex with all of them the one after
the other they go to her and she has sex
with them and it's kind of a rite of
passage thing end of childhood into
adulthood kind of thing it's like that's
the metaphor he was going for but it
just feels weird in the book no no
there's no way to do it there's no way
to nor should translate that no no no
because it's totally inappropriate and
that's not who Beverly is any of the
rest of the time for sure yeah but I'm
very glad about is that they did they
did lean into the whole history of
town with bigotry and racism and
bullying yes the whole book is it
embodies bully bullying whereas
sometimes a lot of annotations are just
like give me the monster that's right I
haven't read the book but I did see the
miniseries and I am interested to see
what they change about the adult section
of the story just with things that
happened in this film I'm interested to
see how it changes that kind of timeline
I'm gonna go ahead and read it seven
gallons of blood in the bathroom out of
seven Beverly marshes oh wow yeah yeah
no I will give it four and a half
Pennywise to death and clouds okay I
would have five Ben is my absolute heart
song I'm gonna give it I'm gonna give it
three Georgie's out of five poor geez
pudding in pies
Ben made me cry a little bit at the end
okay yeah and then when I was telling
you that outside the theater I almost
started crying again you did yeah that a
horror movie couldn't create that is so
cool to me that's the coolest thing I
was really into it
me too I that's how they're like in the
feeder yeah so excited yeah where can
they find you Jake
pineapple boy films on YouTube and come
see Tamra and the time lapse of the
Hellraiser and night marathon
[Music]